que si vous nous disiez bah oui c'était
l'esprit de l'époque c'est malheureux
monsieur Ardisson s'ouvrait ça mieux
plutôt que de me dire il a écrit ça pour
donner l'échange avec les stars
j'en suis convaincu parce que c'est
l'amour et je le respecte c'est l'amour
c'est la recherche de la vérité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça va très bien dans Francine à
la mort du Commandant Cousteau vous vous
êtes retrouvé à la tête de deux
associations la Cousteau Society aux
États-Unis et l'équipe Cousteau en
France et vous assurer depuis la gestion
du lait de votre mari tout en
poursuivant ses actions pour la
protection de l'environnement alors face
à cet héritage l'héritage du Commandant
Cousteau vous ayez pas la garde du
bonnet rouge
vous dites Francine vous êtes pas senti
contrainte finalement quand le
commandant Cousteau est mort de
poursuivre parce qu'en fait c'était déjà
votre passion de depuis longtemps dans
les années 70 vous étiez déjà bénévole
des Amis de la Terre c'est pas un truc
nouveau et finalement quand vous avez
rencontré le commandant Cousteau vous
étiez déjà convaincu du bien fondé de de
son action voilà alors vous l'avez
rencontré en 1976 à Houston au Texas
lors d'un stage de plongée à l'époque
Francine vous étiez hôtesse de l'air à
Air France attention Naceri est parti ça
tombe bien
la série donc les hôtesses de l'air sont
tranquilles ce soir et finalement vous
avez une liaison avec le commandant
Cousteau à partir de ce moment-là mais
vous êtes à Air France vous y restez
jusqu'en 1992 car le commandant Cousteau
était marié
voilà donc vous n'avez pas pu vous
montrer c'est ça non jusqu'à la mort de
sa femme vous avez été d'une discrétion
absolue vous avez sacrifié votre vie
sociale oui c'est vrai mais enfin j'ai
eu la chance pendant 15 ans d'être la
compagne d'un homme exceptionnel je
pense que je peux pas appeler ça
vraiment un sacrifice c'était quand même
c'était c'était 15 ans
discrète vous avez commencé à vous voir
apparaître un peu vers 89 puis bon après
la disparition de sa femme évidemment
vous êtes apparu au grand jour ce qui
est normal d'autant plus nous avions
deux enfants donc il était quand même
temps aussi qu'il faisait une vie
normale
deux foyers quoi avec deux femmes et des
enfants dans chaque vidéo
bon il a fait beaucoup de choses dans sa
vie parce que ça c'est une bon c'est une
anecdote je dirais par rapport
viens viens donc après la disparition du
Commandant Cousteau vous avez été face à
des affaires de succession assez assez
terrible qui ont défrayé la chronique la
brouille avec son fils Jean-Michel qui a
qui a perduré on peut pas dire que ça a
été provoqué par vous en fait je crois
que la brouille avec son son fils c'est
parce que Jean-Michel Cousteau voulait
utiliser des le nom Cousteau pour faire
des des custos 8 sortes dans le
Pacifique en utilisant le nombre pour
faire des des hôtels et des clubs de
vacances quoi oui en fait le commandant
a légué à
l'association qu'il a fondé aux
États-Unis
l'usage de son nom de son image et
l'ensemble de son œuvre donc il
souhaitait que cela soit utilisé
uniquement par cette association et non
pas par des individus donc c'est tout
alors vous avez eu affaire après la mort
du pardon
elle a des yeux sublimes il a dit vous
aussi moi je vais vous laisser
le bleu de tes yeux je ne vois rien de
mieux même le bleu des cieux
il était tout ce qui était bleu
évidemment ça c'est normal ça
m'intéressait non vous avez eu à faire
après le décès du Commandant Cousteau de
vrais problèmes vous avez été assez
courageux d'ailleurs j'ai commencé par
liquider l'équipe américaine pourquoi
avant en 80 94 c'était ça c'était avant
nous avons regardé une équipe américaine
qui est toujours là-bas d'ailleurs avec
laquelle je travaille et une équipe en
France simplement j'ai dû réduire les
effectifs effectivement parce qu'on est
passé par une période très difficile
justement donc je voulais dire réduction
du nombre des adhérents fin des contrats
de production audiovisuelle le
pas-de-calipso 2 pas de chaîne de
télévision Cousteau perte financière
obligée de déménager de changer de
bureau loyer impayés et puis en 1999 le
scandale c'est ce touriste français en
vacances au Canada qui filme un zodiaque
de l'équipe Cousteau qui fonce sur un
groupe de rorquals alors ça évidemment
d'un seul coup ça fait mauvais gens
parce que voilà et qui passe sur une
baleine au moment où elle plonge voilà
alors ça c'est ce qu'on a dit
de la chance effectivement de pouvoir
démontrer que c'était quand même une
illusion d'optique mais c'était surtout
je dirais un procès d'intention et nous
avons pu démontrer qu'on n'avions rien
fait de mal que c'était un peu tout ça
une pièce montée et qu'en fait ce qui
était désagréable c'est que nous avions
l'intention de regarder quelle était
l'impact des touristes sur les 250
baleines qui viennent à cet endroit là
et bon bah ça plaisait pas à tout le
monde mais on avait pas l'intention de
dénoncer ou de faire un scandale ce
qu'on voulait c'était quand même faire
un état des lieux ce qui est notre
métier et je crois que bon certains
zodiaque zodiaque de l'équipe Cousteau
avec une lampe de poche la nuit pour
savoir si il se réveille ça c'est sûr
problème au moment vous avez hérité de
cette succession un petit peu difficile
Francine aujourd'hui effectivement ça
commence à remonter les expéditions
reprennent pour la première fois depuis
la mort du Commandant Cousteau abord de
l’alcium retour sur la mer Rouge à
l'endroit où il avait fait le monde du
silence sur les traces de la première
Calypso pour voir les barrières de
corail donc c'est plus de l'exploration
maintenant c'est du bulletin de santé
parce que l'exploration a été faite il y
a 50 ans aujourd'hui c'est pour voir un
petit peu un petit peu comment ça se
passe et puis aussi ça recommence à
marcher vous sortez en DVD les
documentaires du Commandant Cousteau en
kiosque accompagné de fascicules
explicatifs
le public attendu depuis très longtemps
parce que les films ne passaient plus
depuis quelques années le public
demandait cette série en DVD et nous
avons donc pu le la faire et elle va
sortir le 18 en kiosque et enfin on
pourra donc constituer des collections
ceux qui ont aimé Cousteau où on
retrouver
ces images et pourront les montrer à
leurs enfants leurs petits-enfants alors
je pense que la tradition continue je
vais profiter de votre présence pour
évoquer des points qui voudraient
peut-être mieux éclaircir concernant le
commandant Cousteau il va vous faire
chier il fait ça tout le temps
alors ce qu'on sait parce que tout le
monde le sait ça fait partie de
l'histoire de France le frère du
Commandant Cousteau Pierre-Antoine
Cousteau était rédacteur en chef d'un
journal collaborationniste qui s'appelle
je suis partout il a été condamné à mort
puis gracié à la Libération ensemble on
le savait mais en 1999 François publie
un fake similé d'une lettre de Cousteau
donc votre mari
qui est à Montpellier à l'époque qui est
mal logé et qui dit on aurait des
appartements convenables si on allait
foutu à la porte tous les ignobles outre
donc les Juifs les youtres qui nous
encombrent est-ce que moi j'ai plus
envie d'écouter ce que ce que madame va
répondre
40 je sais plus quelle année c'était 49
c'est très important que je donne une
explication à ça parce qu'effectivement
d'abord tel que c'est paru à ce
moment-là je rappelle que c'était le
jour où Eric orsona prenait le siège de
commandant à la Camille française ce
jour-là comme par hasard c'est le jour
où ça c'est sorti ce que je n'avais
jamais vu et pour lequel j'ai demandé
aux personnes qui avaient connu bien
Cousteau à ce moment-là et qu'on peut
rejoindre sa famille qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé bon il faut savoir qu'à l'époque
le commandant et ça tout le monde je
crois on le sait était dans les services
secrets et qu'il travaillait pour la
marine bon il a été décoré pour ce qu'il
a fait à cette époque là je crois qu'on
peut Légion d'honneur pour ce qu'il a
fait à cette époque là mais quand on a
une connaissance de cette lettre il y a
plein de gens qui ont demandé qu'on
enlève la légende d'honneur oui d'abord
il s'est passé qu'il se planquait il
avait pas le droit vous souvenez que la
marine était quand même à cette époque
là plutôt pétainiste bon et à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce qui se passait c'est
étant donné les fonctions qu'il avait
d'agent secret si je peux dire il était
évident qu'il ne pouvait pas s'exposer
et qu'en conséquence quand il écrivait à
son ami tailleuse je je je précise que
c'était quand même la lettre à taillere
son ami le plus proche quand il lui
écrivait ça si cette lettre avait été
saisie et s'il avait on avait découvert
en fait qu'il protégeait parce que je
tiens à dire la suite qu'il protégeait
ses amis
immédiatement il aurait été arrêté il
aurait été arrêté alors je tiens à dire
ça d'abord parce que jamais au grand
jamais Cousteau on a fait
l'antisémitisme je tiens à dire que
les trois quarts de son conseil
d'administration américain sont
constitués de juifs américains que nous
avons et nous avions
ce qui est sorti à ce moment-là
c'est un fake similaire c'est une photo
de la lettre c'est parce qu'on a le ce
qui serait scandaleux c'est que ce soit
des propos rapportés je rappelle quand
même qu'on relise les circonstances à
cette époque là moi quand j'ai vu ça
sortir dans le journal j'ai dit bon
quelqu'un avait vraiment envie de faire
gratuitement parce qu'on ne peut pas
accuser le commandant de ça il y a des
milliers de preuves que je pourrais
donner et en particulier c'est en
présence de nos amis chouraqués je crois
que vraiment je suis profondément
choquée que quelqu'un est osé faire ça à
Cousteau ce jour-là parce que aller
chercher dans son courrier personnel
quelque chose qu'il a écrit pour une
raison précise à un homme qui était son
plus proche ami
il a écrit ça pour se dédouaner sauf que
je vous dirais matière Francine que à
l'époque pendant la guerre en 42
Cousteau a eu le loisir de montrer ses
films à Paris devant des parters
officiellement
non plus
je pense que c'est une façon de
de détourner la vérité et si j'étais
persuadée du contraire je serai pas là
parce que s'il avait fait quelque chose
dans le sens que vous entendez je pense
que j'aurai le devoir de le dénoncer et
si je suis là c'est parce que je suis
certaine je dis bien certain qu'on ne
peut pas soupçonner un instant Cousteau
d'avoir été antisémite ou d'avoir fait
quoi que ce soit de travers dans ce
domaine là jamais non seulement il l'a
pas fait mais en plus de ça je dis tous
les moments de sa vie ont prouvé autour
de lui que s'il y a eu un drame dans sa
famille ou une horreur pour la famille
vous avez un fils qui est d'un côté
l'autre de l'autre et bien il ne doit
pas lui
être éclaboussés
il a un frère qui lui est vraiment un
des héros de la collaboration qui
devient après le départ de brasillac il
devient rédacteur en chef de je suis
partout donc déjà il y a du bon c'est
son frère je suis d'accord et lui
d'accord mais lui il écrit une lettre et
que j'y présente son film devant des
parters officiellement à Paris en 42
mettez-vous à notre place on se pose des
questions c'est normal pourquoi celui
qui a sorti cette lettre pourquoi il l'a
pas sorti quand Cousteau était là pour
qu'ils puissent s'en expliquer que ce
soit moi qui doivent m'en expliquait
aujourd'hui
je crois qu'on peut
lui donner la solution
paix à son âme et puis passons à autre
chose en ce qui concerne le commandant
je crois qu'il a démontré par tout son
travail
l'amour profond qu'il avait pour les
gens et ça il l'a prouvé en donnant tout
à ses fondations en faisant en ayant
découvert la fragilité du monde en
disant bon ben tout ça il faut que je le
garde pour les générations futures que
je le protège moi j'ai ratio il a créé
ses fondations il aurait pu très bien
vivre en étant une rossignasse
accepter ce que vous pourriez dire aussi
c'est que dans les années 30 des gens
qui avaient été
euh je dirais éduquer élever dans un
certain état d'esprit ça c'est pas vrai
mais son frère son frère est devenu
directeur de je suis partout donc c'est
une famille c'est une famille qui avait
été élu dans cet esprit et à la limite
je trouve que si vous nous disiez bah
oui c'était l'esprit de l'époque c'est
malheureux monsieur Ardisson s'ouvrait
ça mieux plutôt que me dire il a écrit
ça pour donner des choses avec les stars
j'en suis convaincu parce que c'est
l'amour et je le respecte c'est l'amour
c'est la recherche de la vérité parce
que je le lui doit je dois sa mémoire je
dois sa famille aussi parce que dans une
famille où il y a eu un drame aussi
affreux que d'avoir un fils qui trahit
et d'avoir un fils qui est un héros il
est évident que on peut pas faire La
Malga vous comprenez ça c'est pas
possible
un héros qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
d'héroïque il a espionné l'armée
italienne à 7 allez lire le moment où il
était fracturé la le coffre-fort
voilà bon ben allez le lire cette
histoire les conditions dans lesquelles
ça s'est passé et puis bien d'autres
choses et je peux vous dire que
aujourd'hui si je donne cette réponse
c'est parce que j'y crois que j'irai
plus loin parce que je pense qu'il le
mérite et que je veux pas que ça mémoire
ça soit salie parce que ça ça serait pas
bien et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu